les surplus d'électricité disponible au
québec sont actuellement estimés à 32
térawattheures par année jusqu'à
maintenant la principale stratégie a été
de vendre cette électricité aux états
unis aux provinces voisines les surplus
d'hydro-québec pourrait-il maintenant
contribuer à la transition énergétique
et à la relance économique du québec
avec nous pour reprendre dès ce soir
pierre olivier pineau qui titulaire de
la chaire de gestion du secteur de
l'énergie chez ces montréal bonsoir on
s'en remet à ses clients d'où viennent
principalement les surplus d'électricité
du québec
mais les surplus d'électricité du québec
c'est vraiment toute l'électricité
disponible au québec - évidemment nos
usages des usages qu'on en fait notre
consommation locale les engagements
qu'on a auprès de clients externes déjà
des engagements à long terme
c'est ce qui est disponible pour en haut
de la de nos besoins
ouais mais quoi et donc et on va le voir
d'un graphique que vous nous avez fait
parvenir aujourd'hui on a une production
et une importation de 249 térawattheures
c'est la colonne de gauche
et là on s'en va vers la colonne de
droite ses 174 térawattheures devant
d'hydro-québec distribution au québec
et là il ya 1 32 de surplus les césars
exactement et donc il faut retrancher
comme vous l'avez mentionné les 174
térawatts-heure de consommation interne
il ya aussi des pertes sur les réseaux
on voit les pertes 11 térawattheures
dans la transmission six dans la
distribution des des contrats qu'on a
déjà des contrats long terme des petits
contrats de six térawattheures est ce
qui reste c'est le 32 térawattheures qui
est disponible pour différents usages
on en fait quoi aujourd'hui il vient de
québec comme depuis une dizaine d'années
ex porte sur les marchés à court terme
essentiellement à new york et en
nouvelle angleterre exporte ses surplus
là mais malheureusement les prix ces
dernières années ont eu tendance à
diminuer et donc à rendre ses
exportations sur les marchés spot à
court terme de -1
rentable ah oui mais est ce que est ce
que les la hausse des profits est plus
importante que que le niveau de ventes
en termes d'exportation de ces surplus
ces surplus sont toujours exporté à
profit pour hydro québec on a les ventes
externes les exportations correspondent
à environ 15% de la des ventes
d'hydro-québec
mais représentent près de 40% des
profits d'hydro-québec dans la pampa
dernière dernier rapport annuel s'était
de 2019 on a des exportations rentable
mais il ya une tendance à la baisse de
la rentabilité de ses exportations mais
néanmoins hydro québec mise toujours un
peu plus sur les exportations c'est à
dire que ont mis sur les exportations
mais ce que l'on répète cherche à faire
c'est de renouveler le type de contrat
pourrait au lieu d'être exposé à des
marchés à court terme à des fluctuations
quotidiennes voire même horaire est bien
trop québec cherche à garantir à travers
des contrats à long terme qui peuvent
être plus rentable cd des exportations
quels sont les autres possibilités
d'utilisation des surplus et bien c'est
là où ça devient assez palpitant parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de possibilités on
sait que le québec veut lutter contre
les gaz à effet de serre en électrifiant
différents volets de son économie donc
l'électrification des transports des
bâtiments de certaines industries est
une avenue qui peut être intéressant de
développer des nouveaux marchés en
électrifiant mais il ya aussi attiré des
nouvelles industries au québec
développer l'industrie serricole les
serres au québec a mené plus de centres
de données
il y en a même qui voit produire de
l'hydrogène verte pour éventuellement
remplacer comme carburant les sens où
les produits pétroliers se sont une
panoplie de possibilités qui peuvent
être développés pour utiliser ces
surplus si on électrifié nos véhicules
de même atteint ou dans les prochaines
années des zones on vient électrifié une
grosse partie de nos vies que l'on passe
au véhicule électrique peu aux
transports collectifs électriques
est-ce qu'on efface non surplus non
alors ça c'est une question intéressante
on a aujourd'hui au québec à 6 millions
de vies
kühl immatriculé à la société de
l'assurance automobile du québec
si on électrifié un tiers de ces six
millions de véhicules soit deux millions
de véhicules
on n'utiliserait que 6 térawattheures
surnom 32 térawattheures de surplus
rapport donc on a suffisamment d'énergie
pour électrifier une très large
proportion de nos de notre flotte
automobile
mais évidemment il y aurait aussi des
problèmes de gestion de la puissance à
la pointe sans par contre il pourrait y
avoir des défis un mot en terminant
est-ce qu'on doit s'attendre à un impact
dako vide sur les surplus cette année
c'est certain que l'un globalement et
vous venez de mentionner en prêt en
juste avant ce séisme cette entrevue
la demande d'énergie mondiale à diminuer
la demande d'électricité effectivement a
diminué à cause de la cage vide
tous ses magasins qui sont fermées la
demande commerciale d'électricité a
chuté et même si du côté des résidences
on a eu des ménages ont attisé un peu
plus d'énergie
ça ne compense pas donc la cause vide en
fait à un impact d'augmenter les surplus
disponible pour hydro-québec absolument
intéressant merci beaucoup pierre
olivier pineau
ça me fait plaisir merci